so today I'm making my mum's tinder
profile oh dear this is a bit
nerve-wracking what should we say to
ray-ray
I love your body no I smile tan please
don't put the body okay have another sip
of that this guy is [ __ ] sexual I'm
pretty sure I know exactly what my mum
is after in someone I'm very
apprehensive about this I am confident
that I'm going to make my months in a
profile epic because I don't say that
and I'm attended expert as sad as it
sounds for finding the love of our lives
or nights okay
Cheers are you ready not really all
right let's go be good okay let's do
this thing
all righty so this is your main Facebook
photo yeah it's a nice photo you took
that me I did take that yeah how good is
that I'm already winning my mom that's
great I like that look friendly huh now
look this one of you is one of you
there's one of you let's go to the ones
of just you so many of your profile
photos are just cats you don't have many
photos of yourself no I'm not like emic
whoa Savage okay
how about you take a selfie actually
take a selfie yeah oh okay Nick today
maybe um do a bit of a duck face like
true no and I'd like that fine okay so
I don't have to do oh my God look at you
here pussycat years on that was a Fringe
Festival I went to so just uh purrs cat
well when so long guys don't like cats
but you don't want a guy that doesn't
like no is that I like catching from us
I think we should keep this here but
maybe not as the second photo because
you don't want to scream pink what about
you with the Akoo bra oh that's so way
to go now about tummy oh here we go
loyal no time wasters should I include
in brackets my daughter will kill you if
you [ __ ] with me mm-hmm
let's see that gonna scare them away
you be nice g'day fellas ah Nick don't
write that oh dear yes when I was afraid
of nose Helen my interests include my
son Nick would that be a turn-off and
now we can choose their gender if you
want just man hell dose okay your loss a
more effort I put into this the more
there's gonna be random guys free and
talking to you on tinder it's like my
worst nightmare let's say 35 no no no no
no no no that's too young
have you ever heard the expression Yolo
no all right are you ready so I'm
searching let's start I think mom oh
okay whoa that is the most pixelated
photo I've ever seen and he has the same
name as my dad oh no turn off I've been
single for a while don't admit that no
no no oh no he has a beard everything
about this guy I [ __ ] hate and a
daughter with snot coming out of her
nose
it's weird this guy has cut his kid out
of the photo you know when they show you
photos of murderers in the papers or
wrong news this is the guy I don't trust
his face I kind of want to punch it
actually so funny we both like the same
we have the same taste in 55 year old
man
Wow all these guys are just not good
enough Yuma
are we gonna match no we got a match
no that was too quick I created mom's
profile five minutes ago this guy's
suits on tinder Oh Oh can I just have a
look at him again oh my god we have just
found the cowboy of her dreams a softy
for animals he doesn't smoke I want him
to be my dad here we go
that guy's dreamy is [ __ ] back back I
think I'm in love with him I'm gonna
send a message no no oh okay what does
that mean what's good I open up the
cabin no I'm really nervous because I
like Gavin I like the look nervous
nervous oh my god that's a knife what we
have a match with no that's them how's
it hanging no oh my god mom you're
killing it I'm just matched with a guy
who has the body of a Trojan horse haha
this guy's [ __ ] sexual Gavin is asking
where my mum lives I'm just gonna go
Walt slow down
this guy's cute ba-ba-ba-ba in Lebanese
means father I think it's a sign wow we
must see how do you feel you're matching
with all these babes it's fun right
who's my confident yeah well if you
don't share where you live our chat may
be short oh [ __ ] this guy good
I hate this guy see you later [ __ ] boy
so he's asked how are you I'm gonna say
I'm better now no dad that's the world
what are we in a strip joint like how I
speak to people in strip joint [ __ ] I
hate men like ten men want to meet up
with you okay so we have whiskey the
ideal guy I wanted to find for my mum
isn't on there we haven't even spoken to
some of the matches we have no time to
speak to all these men
there we go mum you have two dates thank
you I'm sorry seems it's not gonna work
out fine by me Mick how good a guy is
this guy
on his criminal record and everything
about him and shot with her in your bed
you